hello to welcome to this video playing
meat grinder from Turkey this is very
popular than turkey i know from chess
students of mine they tell you again so
can i really aged 3 i always like to see
that g5 is what's gonna try to go for
now here we go g5 yeah this is still
there is still possible
g5 now is probably correct wow wow this
is playable I have a hard time to
believe that f2 hangs h6 Hanks and takes
Bishop takes and Bishop f3s a disastrous
okay okay um can even take here but
teenage fall so it's good let's do this
check so okay go into a king to e7 or to
d7 is it a difference no ok let's not
spend so much time so it's getting going
back okay so look H ATM
Crean h1 made no move I think f3 I'll
take the rook
you
oops I know it's too late white resides
and the only way to kind of keep keep
playing the cs35 I think this kind of
position I still like black Ian but it's
I mean I've got the edge file open for
not much but I think he has to this
pretty much loses wish you have to is
even more convincing check yes I saw the
move but I thought it doesn't really
matter I mean I saw that it's it's it's
something to check but here I didn't see
anything directly and this seems to win
the house minus 22 okay this is probably
a strong thread but this should win a
swell right yeah it was check it's just
too much f2 Hanks and he can never play
g3 because of this and he aged eight
kills on the age file yeah it's just an
incredibly dangerous to play with age
three and allow this g 5o tech it's very
very dangerous okay well thanks for
watching